ce que cherchait il l'avait l'euphorie
aura été de courte durée
[Musique]
dix jours après la légalisation la
société québécoise du cannabis devait
réduire ses heures d'ouverture pénurie
oblige mais me châtain des points tel
engouement que les scuds essayer d'y
avoir reçu seulement 40% des stocks
qu'elle avait commandé la pression est
donc maintenant sur les producteurs
on entend nos consommateurs on sait
qu'on n'est pas la hauteur de leurs
attentes
chez exo seul fournisseur dont le siège
social est basé au québec on met les
bouchées doubles pour répondre à la
demande l'entreprise cultive
présentement 65 mille plants et
quintuple eura sa production d'ici le
printemps prochain
son pdg se dit satisfait du travail de
ses employés
mais il admet avoir dû apporter des
ajustements de nous autres on on a
déterminé de nous même qu'elle est à
bord est le mix de produits par exemple
que les clients demanderai c'est certain
qu'il ya certains produits qui ont été
plus populaires que d'autres et puis on
était prêt à ajuster la production en
conséquence
surtout que les clients ont été beaucoup
plus nombreux que prévu se lancent un
nouveau iphone piteux état des lignes et
par là une journée peut-être deux on a
encore des lignes et au magasin escudé
cd semaine après c'est une demande
absolument incroyable et surélevée à ce
qu'on s'attendait pour cette chercheuse
de l'institut cydia ou la pénurie de
cannabis était prévisible mais pas la
rapidité avec laquelle elle s'est
manifestée pas trop chaud mais on est
sûr d'avoir un taudis quand même ne
serait dans la rue les prix compétitifs
ont attiré les clients alors que santé
canada tardé à émettre des permis de
production
les autres pointent à quelques mois de
la légalisation les producteurs
n'avaient accumulé que quelque 60 tonnes
de stock alors que la demande annuelle
totale de cannabis est évalué à plus de
600 tonnes au colorado le marché a mis
trois ans à atteindre l'équilibré et
plus la pénurie sera longue plus les
gouvernements perdront des revenus
jusqu'à 100 millions de dollars en un an
selon le site yahoo
on a toute une ligne de production
viennent entre temps chez exo on
continue à prendre de l'expansion et on
prépare déjà la prochaine étape celle de
la légalisation des produits comestibles
ici hugo lavallée radio canada québec
[Musique]